Hello everybody, it is a little after 4, sorry we weren't able to do a live zoom call today
my internet crash, we had a storm here, it hit a server, and I tried to connect my mobile
hot spot, and it's not working, it's not enough power to do a zoom call, even though I practiced
it worked just fine a little or yesterday, so we're gonna just go through the questions and that we're
submitted, so there's a benefit of getting your questions submitted, I guess, so sorry about that,
okay, do you think the jackhammer I amplify or a true rife grouty mat would be beneficial to add to my
f122 rife, we've talked about this lots and lots of times, but the jackhammer amplifier is good for people who
don't like to cuddle with their bulb, so if you can't cuddle with your bulb for whatever reason,
somebody asked a question, later on it will talk about that they think the bulb is giving them
rigging in the ears, and it's causing rigging in the ears, well then put the bulb under the bed with the amplifier,
that will help with that, so because it does give off a noise and if it's closer to your ears it could
bother you, some people for whatever reason don't like to struggle with their bulb, then you could put the
bulb under the bed with the amplifier, is the grouty mat benefit to add, well we have the grouty
sheets in our store that you could purchase, just make sure you put the grouty sheet on the lower half
of your bed underneath your fitted sheet, so it goes between your mattress and your fitted sheet,
underneath your fitted sheet, so it's been on the lower half of your bed, so it's on just your
waist down, that's how you want to use the grouty sheet, well should you use a grouty mat with a bulb,
no you should only use the grouty mat with the foot mat with the higher probe wave,
the website says that the jackhammer amplifier will accelerate the output of your true right bulbs,
which is right, so it increases the amplification, but you don't need it any higher amplification
if you're struggling with the bulb, it's already going through you, you don't need to go through you
and then through the next room, you're just needed to get it in your body, so where the jackhammer shines
as if it's a wave from your body, you do not get EMF exposure with either of those, so you don't have
to worry about that, I'm taking the aroma clear, the estro clear, and the sulforazine, I have had
good plant tests for the last two years, I'm 75 years old, recently I read that there's some natural
progesterone cream made from YAMS, would this be a good thing to put on, do you think this would be
helpful thing to do, why or why not, so if a person has, let's say they have colon cancer, let's say they
have, you know, brain cancer, let's say they have a cancer that any cancer that is not
hormonally driven in any way or as a chance to be in hormonally driven, then you're fine using
progesterone cream. If you have a cancer that is hormonally driven, then you do not want to use
progesterone cream because progesterone will store in the cells and will aromatize into estrogen,
so you do not want to use progesterone cream if you have hormonally driven cancer. A friend of a friend
attributes, attributes his beating stage 3 colon cancer by the supplement
apogenin, so what are, what are, what are apogenins? Do you test for this? I typically don't test for
that, apogenins are flavonoids, I think they're, I think they're in oregano, there's a high amount
of oregano, there's, they're in onions, I think they're broccoli, they're in a lot of your vegetables,
so there are apogenins in your green strength. If you were going to do oregano, you could use it
for that, and maybe the, so it is a flavonoid, so whenever we talk about, would anybody ask questions
about inflammation, I have inflammation, what should I do about that? And I always talk about
seems like almost every Zoom call we talk about the flavonoids, so your typical flavonoids that you
think of are curcumin, green TX tract, Boswellia, Resveratrol, those are your most powerful flavonoids,
but there's a lot of different flavonoids in vegetables, that's why I like the green strength,
because it's got such a mixture of different vegetables and it's just a whole food product,
that's why you should be your vegetables, because they have different things in it, they have a
synergistic effect. Could you just take this product? Yes, you could take that product too,
so but it is in the flavonoid category, and it is highly anti-inflammatory,
corseted, green TX tract, I said, I think already white willow bark, and
sticky dental, all those kinds of things have flavonoids in it, so they're anti-inflammatory,
so using any of those flavonoids can be quite helpful for any inflammation,
with any disease process, there's inflammation, and certainly with cancer there's inflammation.
When I started the keto diet experience, leg cramps at night, I researched and saw that potassium
supplementation might help, it seems to, although it seems to, although I can create leg cramps
at will, simply by pointing my leg toes, so obviously I don't do that normally,
okay, so when a person could kind of create a leg cramp, because you're basically tight-need,
your muscles, and then they cramp up, that's typically a side of kneading minerals, so if you're tight-knop,
if you tighten up your leg and it goes into a cramp, or you tighten up your foot in a certain way,
it goes into a cramp, typically that's a side of beans, deficient in some minerals,
so taking some minerals can help, and electrolytes like potassium can be very helpful,
so yes, taking potassium can be extremely helpful. So I manage these leg cramps for the most part,
but I wonder what you attribute them to as it relates to a ketogenic diet.
If you're not getting a lot of minerals in your ketogenic diet, if you're staying away from
vegetables that have any kind of carbohydrates, you could be missing the vegetables that have minerals
in it, maybe that's it, I'm not sure, exactly, everybody's definition of a ketogenic diet,
what they've chosen to, you know, the ketogenic diet is a little different, so typically you're not
going to get minerals in any useful complex in meat products, and most ketogenic diets are high in
meat products, so maybe that's what you're missing, it's just minerals. You took me off turmeric and
curcuclear, and I added intentside porotype to see if the rash would go away, so this person had a
rash, and what we were trying to see is, if the possibility of the rash was due to a sensitivity or
that the person has antibodies to turmeric, so turmeric is a food, it's a spice, right, and you can
develop antibodies to turmeric, it's not really very common, but I've seen it before, so you do a
Syrex 10 panel, it measures for all sorts of different things, and one of them is turmeric, and
I've seen people have positive antibodies for turmeric, they can't take turmeric, and I was just
curious to see if this person's rash was due to the turmeric, so I had them go off of the turmeric
to see if the rash would go away without having to spend 500 plus dollars to do a Syrex array 10,
that says, now my rash is increased to other areas, and I'm wondering if not reacting to the enzymes,
we'll see, this is a call in elimination diet, you're trying to eliminate things that you think
could possibly be causing a rash, you could certainly eliminate the intentside porotype, I just highly
doubt that the rash is due to the enzymes, I think it's something else, if the rash didn't go away,
and it seemed to get worse after you went off the turmeric, then certainly not the turmeric, I'd go
back on that for sure because that's going to be a good anti-inflammatory, there's something else
going on, there's something maybe in your diet that is causing it, you're going to have to continue
to kind of look at things that maybe in your diet that could be causing the rash, there's just so
many things, there's going to be another rash question coming up here, there's just so many things that
could cause a rash, usually it's a histamine type reaction, but it could be histamine reaction from
something you're breathing in, from something you're eating food-wise, from dyes, calories, chemicals,
until you're exposed to just outside in your yard, oh, I just started this rash a month ago,
well maybe it's just because you just started getting outside in the summertime, maybe it's from
something you're spraying on your lawn, I mean there's just, you have to kind of be an investigator
to try to figure something that's stuck out, even running some functional medicine panels might not
pinpoint why the person has the rash, so because it's something in the environment that you can't
always test for, with the increased dose of the intense I'm forte in the last three days,
I've noticed a returning the rash to my neck, and it could be that, so let's eliminate that,
let's see if that's it, that could be, I'd kind of doubt that if that's it, but anything's possible,
the neck and knee rash is itch, I wonder if the enzymes could be causing the rash as I've
noticed it increase in gas with the new changes, well I think that's a little bit different,
my primary position, what physician wants me to go on an oral antibiotic for my left knee rash
and my wondering how this will occur, well I don't understand why an oral antibiotic for a rash,
so an antibiotic is only going to help a bacterial infection, so let's see things that the
rash is caused from a bacterial infection, which it possibly could be, but with gut issues,
I don't know if I would jump to that right away, doing another cheek swab might be helpful too,
I would go back to my first idea of making sure that you're doing some different food
eliminations to see if there's anything else that you could be reacting to, an rash question from
somebody a few weeks ago too, and it's, you can eat things, don't think that, oh I'm
eating this for so long, it certainly can't be that, you can develop antibodies to things that you
eat a lot of, and that's one of the reasons why you can develop antibodies to things that is because
you eat a lot of them and you've eaten for a long time, so just because you've never had a problem,
quote unquote, with that thing in the past as I mean you won't in the future or that might be what
is currently the cause of the problem, so if you're going to try to get to the bottom of this
with an elimination diet that you're going to eliminate is many of these dietary things that
you might be causing it as well. Is there anything lab results that would indicate an issue I saw
come up that mentioned anemia? This person said to their labs and you certainly do have subendemia
and we should probably set up a call for this person who sent in their labs. I was discussing the
value of hyperbaric oxygen to a hyperbaric oxygen tank with a deo-friend of mine and a question came
up that hyperbaric oxygen increased the metabolic activity of hyper metabolic malignant cells.
I haven't seen any evidence of that. So this is the difference between
increasing O2 and increasing O negative. So understand chemistry a little bit. Hyperbaric oxygen
increases oxygenation of tissue increases O2, which can really help with cells. I don't think
it increases metabolic activity with malignant cells. Matter of fact there's enough studies that
show that it helps with cancer. The only thing I have negative against hyperbaric oxygen is that
it's you almost have to have a hyperbaric oxygen tank in your house because you have to all the
studies that have done hyperbaric oxygen have done it on a daily basis. And it tends to be better
for brain issues. Hyperbaric oxygen really shines with brain cancer and brain issues and dementia
issues. That's where hyperbaric oxygen really shines. For colon cancer, for liver cancer,
it's pretty iffy. And it takes time, you know, you're doing it for at least an hour every day.
So, you know, it's not one of my favorite therapies for that thing. But if a person has brain cancer,
hyperbaric oxygen would be something that would be viable to add. It does seem that the rife is
causing my ears to ring. Here's that question about the ears to ring last night. When I turn the rife,
turn down the rife, the tumors in my rife breasts stung intensely. So, I think that is a very good
thing. So much that I turned it off for relief at the insights. Well, I think when you talk about
good-paid, bad-paid, when you have tingly feeling any type of feeling in your tumor when you turn the
rife on, I see that only as a very, very, very positive thing. Rigging in your ears is another thing.
That's not necessarily a positive thing. So, that's where you use the hammer tube with the amplifier,
the jackhammer amplifier under the bed might be a good thing to do. Can you tell me what supplements
are antioxidants besides my greens first drink? So, the greens first drink. Yeah, there's some
antioxidants in there. I would not classify that as an antioxidant to stop taking for the 48 hours
during chemo. I would keep taking that. The only thing that I would stop taking during the 48 hours,
I certainly would do any vitamin C either oral or IV vitamin C. I wouldn't do that. I wouldn't do
alpha-lopeic acid. I wouldn't do glutathione. Those are the really three main things. Curcumin as an
antioxidant is an antioxidant. Maybe you want to stop that. I would not stop the green drink. So,
I'd say curcumin, alpha-lopeic acid and glutathione. Those are the three main things that I'd stop.
Those are the most, really, the more powerful antioxidants. I mean, you're eating food. That's got
antioxidants. It's not you like trying to eliminate all antioxidants. You just try to eliminate
like really high dose things that would negate some of the chemo. A lot of alternative doctors don't
even suggest that. They say that you should load up on antioxidants while you're even for those 48
hours. They say you should they just don't stop people from doing it. I think contrary to that,
I think just give it 48 hours off of that. You could certainly fast all your supplements for those
40 hours if you want, but your other cells do need nutrition too. I certainly wouldn't stop the
green drink. My last blood work was done in the middle of March. I believe that you recommended blood
work every three months. I'm a little past that I'm afraid. I'm wondering what exactly you'd
recommend. I have checked this time. Last lab continued to show slightly lower cholesterol, but still in
the high range. Do I need to recheck that? We're not really doing a lot for your cholesterol issue or
concentrate on your cancer, but certainly it doesn't cost really any more to get that rechecked. So
getting a lipid panel would be a smart thing to do. Nothing seems to bring that down significantly,
because we're not really trying to bring that down. On a side note, I could easily feel the tuber
by right breast that male wanted biopsy, not sure if it's bigger, certainly it's not smaller though.
I'm thinking that tuber tests would, but which ones. So we have a female tuber panel,
that would be the one to do the female tuber marker panel. Is there anything else in particular?
Certainly a CVC and certainly a complete metabolic panel. Cheek swab? Yes, but let's wait till after
the blood test. Blood pressure continues to run high anywhere from 171 to over 74. The lowest is
been 127 over 65. Yeah, that's where we wanted to stay. Let's get it to stay there. I have not had
wellness physical in going on two years because they will put me on blood pressure medication.
I don't want to do that. They also push for tests like mammograms. I didn't want to do bold
density. I don't want to do. So yeah, let's just get that blood work done. If you do our
complete wellness panel, that also has thyroid test, and that's always good to look at that too.
Is it safe to do your parasite program with kids? I know, digestive enzymes and SBI.
Protector okay for them, but what about proverbophuge or the paratocin or the pylora cell?
All of those are safe with kids. You just have to dose them based on their weight. So let's say,
you know, it says the adult dose, it just pretends three times a day on something. So if you figure
an adult is about 150 pounds, if you have a child that's 50 pounds, you only want to give them one
a day. So just dose it down for their size. Those are fine with kids. Of course it depends on what age
kid. If you got a two-year-old, I wouldn't do that at all, but if you have like five, six, seven,
eight-year-olds, certainly you could do that absolutely. Could you recommend a good clean gluten-free
sourdough bread recipe? No, I'd recommend maybe go on an Instagram looking for a gluten-free bread group.
I don't know you could Google it. You could look up on YouTube. I don't know.
Which binders and gums should be avoided? So yeah, you're talking about dietary binders
in like prepared foods and things. I'm sure the question that you're talking about, you're talking
about binders and gums that are in supplement products. There's really none that really should be
certainly avoided with chemo or anything like that. And this person who asked this question,
I'm going to give them a list of what to take for starting chemo.
Does a daily order detoxine protocols matter? Good question. Exercise, I do lymph massage, I do
rebound, I do soda, I do coffee edibles. Is there an issue with what order you do them in?
I don't, you know, just whatever order makes sense for you and your lifestyle.
Yeah, it doesn't make sense to be exercising and going to soda. Maybe that doesn't make sense because
you're birding off a lot of minerals and then you're going to in a sauna. So it's kind of doing
similar things. Exercise in sauna is doing a coffee in them and then doing a castoral pack,
you know, right after that, a good thing to do. I don't know, it makes it kind of you're doing
similar things there. So breaking them up, you just kind of got to think through some things.
I don't think there's any perfect order for anybody or anything of these, you know.
So it's just should be, you just try to use your common sense of those things.
But using castoral packs on my deck and liver overnight is it's a good thing or is it too long?
Typically, we recommend castoral packs doing that like 30 minutes, doing it overnight.
I know people have done it. We've had people, you know, maybe on this call that I've done it,
or on this video, not on the call. But yeah, if you're not having ill effects of it,
I don't think there's a problem with it. Watching your videos on chemo, you suggest sort of
on the right immediately after an infusion, but we live in an hour and a half from the hospital.
If they would allow my life in the infusion, would it be a good idea to run it during the infusion?
Yes, it would. I don't know if they will allow it. And certainly, just go home and run it.
Don't worry about the hour and a half ride. I've had people hook up the right in their car and a
realtor once put really bad breast care cancer and she just refused to stop working. She said,
she said her car constantly. She hooked up the right in her car right in her car all the time.
That was interesting. But typically, if you just go home and run the right, that's a 99% of the people do.
I've been getting caker sores on my tug. They're irritating sore. What are they from? What can I do to heal
them? Well, Lizied. It's going to be the last. It can be helpful for caker sores. Also,
taking calcium lactate and putting them directly on the caker sores have been known to help.
Caker sores are from a change in pH of your mouth. That's what they're from. While caker sores are
from herpes, simplex virus that lives in the nerve ganglion, in the trigeminal nerve ganglion,
in your up by your cheek. That herpes virus lives there and it comes out when there's a change in
pH in your mouth. That's why people get a colsor after they suck on a lemon. They'll get a colsor
because it changes the pH. It's a drastic change in pH in their mouth. Whatever you have a drastic
change in pH in your mouth, a colsor can come out. That's why people could go months or even years or
little colsor that also get a colsor when they eat something really super spicy or they have some
lemon juice or they drink something that would acidic or alkaline that could throw off the pH in
the mouth and that just gives the opportunity. Herpes, simplex is an opportunistic organism and it
comes right down in the trigeminal nerve and forms the blister in the mouth. That's what it is. L
lysine can be helpful. There's, you could probably google a bunch of other different natural
things that can be helpful with it too. Years ago, not knowing better, I let a dentist take on all my
mercury fillings. He did so just by drilling them all out. I assume this person say that they didn't
use a mercury vapor, vacuum, didn't use a rubber dam, didn't close off your nasal cavity.
Yeah, I know firsthand other issues with that. Also, I still have two crowns that are covered in white
but show silver due to my receding gum line. Yeah, this is a problem a lot of people have silver
fillings underneath a crown and they don't even know it. Also, until recently, I used to do oil
fully daily, not knowing if I have silver in my mouth. Also, I was fully vaccinated as a child
in the other health. My mental toxicity be a contributing factor to cancer as well as other health
factors. Well, absolutely, mental mercury has an aluminum in vaccines and things and steps
that they're sprayed in the air is causing all sorts of health issues. It's a huge, huge, huge problem.
The difficult thing is that you can't really do, you know, chelation therapy or try to
keylate the side of your body when you have such large quantities still lodged in your teeth.
I've had people that want to get their mercury fillings open. They have so many literally that
have to get every tooth so they're both pulled. It's just impossible task. You just got to learn to fight
what giants that you can fight without opening up battles that you're not able to defeat. So,
that's a mixed metaphor I apologize. I said to emails with photos of rashes and welts
were you able to see though? Yes, I was. Like I said before, it's very difficult to
determine the cause of a rash sometimes. Well, yeah, it's easy when you, you know, you go out and
you rub against poison ivy and you get a rash. So, that is a topical dermatitis where there is
a rash because of a topical irritant. But when there is a systemic irritant that's causing a
dermatitis of some kind, it's difficult to find out what that is because even if you took a sample
of the pus of a rash or you took some sort of microscopic sample from the rash, you're still not
going to see anything. Most I'm in the rash itself because the rash itself is a histimated
inflammatory reaction due to some irritant or the irritant is necessarily present in the rash itself.
So, it's hard to analyze, you know, the cause of that rash sometimes. Anything that could cause
inflammation, it could cause a rash. Anything that could be an irritant can cause a rash.
So, you have to do some digging into what could be an irritant in that person's case. And it's
that's not an always an easy thing to figure out. Would ortho spores be a good thing to take
during these upcoming weeks of chemo? What about liver and D? So, I told this person,
we just had a call and we're going to do a workup for them on what they should be taking for their
chemo. All right, sorry about not being able to take live calls. Today, we'll be back on
the slide in regular and next week, Lord Willid and we'll go from there. All right, bye-bye.